now that kenobi has come to an end
people probably wondering what is next
and my friends i'm the answer for that
for you it is the upcoming and or tv
show which releases on the 31st of
august i believe the first season will
go for 12 episodes and then they got a
second season confirmed which will go
for another 12 episodes correct me if
i'm wrong on that anyway i believe this
series is going to surprise everyone i
think this series is going to be
insanely good and if there's one thing
that we can confirm it is that the show
looks visually spectacular like just
look at the visuals here guys this looks
insane i'm going to be honest this is
the best looking star wars tv show we
have seen to date this is what i wish
kenobi would have looked like andor is
actually shot on location where
zavasta's tv shows were shot mostly
using the volume now the volume is a
great piece of technology but you can
really see that it does lack in certain
elements because andor is shot on
location and it just looks miles better
it honestly just looks like a star wars
film like it just visually looks
incredible and the story i feel like is
going to surprise people as well it's
something different something new
obviously we got cassin and andal on the
show and one mothma so some familiar
faces but i feel like it's going to be a
really grounded story and it's going to
really surprise people we're going to
see coruscant again as we can see the
senate room and everything and man as
i've mentioned probably 478 times this
looks visually just incredible and we
can also see clone troopers here so you
know there are things that we know and
love that are going to be in this show
but also feel like we're going to get a
lot of this grounded war story elements
that we did see in rogue one but maybe
on a smaller scale and for the people
who do love their cameos i feel like
there is definitely a potential for that
as well just because of when this is set
in the timeline but anyway i could speak
about the show for a long time it's it's
honestly my most anticipated solo show
now and i do wish kenobi looks like this
because you know it just feels like such
a big budget difference between these
two shows and surely disney knew that
kenobi was going to be the biggest show
ever so they should have allocated the
best of the best for that project and
given it the biggest budget boomerang
what do you guys think of this show are
you guys excited are you looking forward
to it let me know in the comment section
below and also subscribe to support the
channel